autour de kiev les barrages sont partout
jusque sur les petites routes de
campagne où les agriculteurs ont pris
leurs fusils de chasse
pendant que les civils fuient en masse
la capitale les troubles ukrainienne
elle se déploie
un bref arrêt dans cette station essence
puis ses hommes iront traquer les
groupes armées russes
on adorait show mode les russes pensé
que ça allait être facile chiot jobin
comme les antilles ont pris la crimée
qu'ils allaient pouvoir occuper notre
sol ukrainien sans même avoir besoin de
tirer une balle
mais c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
je veux m'adresser aux soldats russes
sont beaux les gars revenez ici vous
allez voir comment on va venir vous
accueillir
à quelques 30 kilomètres de kiev dans
une zone où les chars n'ont pas encore
pénétré
sergueï se prépare à passer la nuit dans
un hôtel il a décidé de retourner à kiev
malgré la menace russe un choix
difficile annoncé à ses parents
why faut qu'une douzaine pourquoi
poutine fait-il st
pourquoi fait-il pleurer nos merdes
ukrainienne
j'ai parlé à ma mère aujourd'hui
et elle comprend pourquoi je dois être à
kiel mais comme juillet par go il y a
tant de gens qui ont fui la ville
que certains doivent rester pour la
défendre
c'est
sergei est ingénieur depuis l'invasion
russe il ne travaille plus et ne pensent
qu'à aider comme il peut
ma conviction c'est que je n'ai pas le
droit de tuer un autre homme
mais si les russes entrent pour
s'emparer de kiev je ne sais pas comment
je réagirais nous sommes une nation
différente un peuple différent
dans nos esprits et nos âmes s'il vous
plaît les russo ne nous attaquez pas
réveil à l'aube prêt pour le départ
avec ses amis ils doivent apporter des
médicaments et de la nourriture
comme à mon ami qui devait venir me
chercher ici ne répondent plus au
téléphone
je ne sais pas pourquoi peut-être est-il
mort et bethesda il fait partie des
forces d'autodéfense de la ville
territoriaux défense osé citer tout peut
arriver
bon ok je vais devoir aller à pied à
kiev alors
il part seul pour une capitale assiégée
il rejoindra les comités de volontaires
qui aident les civils ou prendra les
armes
sergei fera ce qu'on lui demande pour
défendre son pays